I do feel like you guys kind of
influenced a generation of I feel like
SOB y'all probably don't get as a group
the credit you deserve in terms of you
guys influenced a lot of La guys yeah
for so I feel like a lot of like how you
guys are rapping the flow y'all had like
kind of the slightly offbeat [__] like I
feel like you guys kind of and this can
be said about the Bay Area in general
with a lot of [__] that happens
you guys influence a lot of [__] but
don't necessarily get the credit for the
influence that you guys have on hip-hop
even La hip-hop do you guys did you guys
notice that like happening because you
guys are the hottest [__] moving and a
lot of people in La started to pop up
that in my opinion sounded a lot like
what you guys are doing yeah did you
notice that yeah for so you know how
that [__] go like we don't really you
know how that [__] go like we don't
really get no we don't get credit for a
lot of [__] but you feel me like
hit the scene cry about it and pout for
real I mean like it is what it is at the
end of the day though a lot of [__]
that you feel me a lot of [__] I run
into like they're paying [__] homies
like when they see a [__] but like
[__] probably not just gone ain't
nobody's gonna want to put it out there
like oh [__] I ain't gonna lie
I I really like [__] really base my
flow off the young [__] like we young
[__] like maybe if we was like
some OG's or something in the game like
[__] it'd be easier to pay
homage to be like oh I really been grew
up listening young [__] you feel me
don't know about not too many
[__] want to give a young [__]
too much credit you feel me they think a
young [__] big-headed oh they don't
want to give a a young [__] that much
juice that much power but [__] don't
be you feeling me like I think it's be
on some humble [__] [__] not really
tripping off that [__] like it is what
it is like like I think of you guys and
I think like Shoreline Mafia had like a
lot of
Sons like he's kind of yeah so you gotta
remember like one [__] might
copy us and then the [__] that
copied us a [__] might have
copied them Mighty not even not
listening like it's just it's just so
much recycled [__] going on you don't
know who a [__] really getting
[__] from like we started a lot of [__]
but like a lot of [__] got recycled like
you feel me like [__] get it's
like lost files like [__] don't
know where they got this and that from
right it's all good though like I'm glad
to see that [__] credit away
for everybody to eat for real cause a
lot of the young [__] scene was dead
it wasn't no young [__] really rapping
for real like we taught young [__] how
to talk [__] you feel me just be free
you feel me uh speaking mind it's a lot
of cappers up on this [__] too that you
they making no way though you feel me
congratulate them boys
feeding a lot of young [__] off the
wave and a [__] started but I
ain't gonna say [__] we all
started this [__] as a group but right
you feel me like I mean they ain't
tripping out that [__] let them boys go
crazy how are you feeling about the
younger generation in the bay right now
who are some of the young young guys
that you're [__] with that are kind
of obviously coming up there's some
young [__] going crazy ebk cam going
crazy from Stockton yeah DB dude from
Zach's dope oh yeah DB about a bag you
going crazy a young [__] uh mods for
real he going crazy
who the [__] else uh my young [__]
going crazy little buddy Joe ski a
little Sculpey baby brothers all the GBS
who else uh they they are from Vallejo
too
uh who has gone crazy Fredo bags this I
can last a lot of young [__] going
crazy it's really a young [__] world
right now too I can't even keep up with
who all really going crazy but shout out
all them boys like yeah are you would
you you said solo projects early does
that mean you got any collapse here
coming or would you drop like a whole
tape with somebody or a whole EP with
the artist
a year I probably I'll probably end up
releasing one or two of them by the end
of the year well who I ain't gonna say
all that and you feel me it's some [__]
in the works I gotta [__] I got some
[__] I got some [__] anybody from is it
from the bay or outside of the bay uh
yeah in front of bay in front of bay
I don't know you and little Russell will
be crazy yeah for so it'd be like a very
good contrast of styles and content it
had me on my profit [__]
at least [__] around do some [__] for so
we got to do some [__] like molding just
one song like we got to do a couple like
for the culture for sure man